hello and welcome to munich security
conference in our youtube studio and i'm
very happy that today the belarusian
opposition leader svetlana chika noska
is joining us
how are you
uh hello everyone uh but i always doubt
how to answer the question how are you
if it's not like usual politeness
because
i really uh
uh going through difficult times and uh
it's very often i'm overtired i'm
so sad i'm communicating with people
whose parents or relatives are in jail
and it's so devastating but
there are small victories that inspires
me so
it's a time difference
i'll i'll go to a sentence that you that
you said 2020 maybe you remember this
you said i never want to do any of these
i was never overly political i never
planned to run for office
but
i will never give up
do you remember when you said this
uh not actually you know it was my
feelings and uh i could tell it in
different
uh situations or places you said it as a
ted talk and when i
listened to what you were saying and i
was wondering now after two years when
you look back
what would you have done differently
you know it's a big advantage that we
can't go in the past and change
something
you know because you know it's
impossible and we have to deal with what
we have
i could say that i would never go for
candidacy into a president i
wouldn't they
take this step knowing what
happened after this
but i did this and
i saw a historical moment
in my country and when people woke up
where they believed in themselves and
they found strength to
say no to 27 years dictatorship in our
country i'm happy with this and but i
could never imagine that i could see
such a hell from uh belarusian regime
towards its own people
it's interesting when i listen to you
say sometimes it's very hard it's very
hell but the same times you have
inspirational very strong moments that
you live
what's one of the moments you
experienced the last two years that it's
in your heart and you say this is a
moment forever
these were the moments when i saw uh
hundreds of thousands of builders on the
streets who believed in themselves who
overstepped their fear and managed to
go out to the streets and say
enough we are fed up with this
dictatorship we want to have better life
in better country we are wonderful
hard-working people and we know that we
deserve better future those pictures
from
after elections they are will be always
in my heart
at the same time
uh the pictures of tortured people
you know of blue people that went out
from prisons also you can't just
eliminate these pictures from from your
mind
today when we
look at what you achieved you are an
inspiration for a whole young generation
in belarus
and um
a lot of them look up to you
see you as a leader
someone who's
changing
what do you think what did you change
the last two years
you know and i'm looking with
inspiration on all those young people
who inspire me who every day under
such a threat everyday threat they are
doing small steps towards changes
and uh
it's not me who is changing everything
it's all of us
because uh
any leader is uh nobody without people
around
so we are like inspiring each other we
see how far we can go in in our goals
and
this unity uh
like pushes us forward
and
we really achieved a lot we changed our
perception
of the situation we are not ready to
live
in
in this country with this government
anymore we really deserve a better
future and we realize this
but what
else we achieved is
we found a lot of lies among
democratic countries for 27 years our
regime was losing step by step support
of the countries and now we
see such a unity of uh
you know democratic leaders of parties
of people around us
and
i always say that belarus unites
we even people with different views on
many different things have a
uh singular opinion about about the
situation in belarus because they
understand what we are fighting for what
our aims or to our values
you when you when you're talking you say
we
who do you mean with we who do you
present today
i'm presenting here below some people
with alternative opinion and we are uh
you know about eighty ninety percent of
billers and people
because there are no official numbers
saying how many are pro or are how many
are um
are supporting or non-supporting
but while you're talking
there's also a lot of hope do you still
have hope
that change will happen the way you want
to see belarus
it's not about hope uh i'm sure that
one once we will gain what we want
and uh because
i saw belarusians
uh in 2020 i saw the their eyes
i saw
they hope at that time
yes i understand that we
wanted to achieve
changes rather fast
but
we couldn't do this because of cruelty
of the regime but for more than one year
and a half people are still fighting
people are still doing everything
possible to
make the small steps towards our aim and
this is priceless
in order to understand more what you're
going through what are the challenges in
every day's
life for you in order to achieve this
change that you want to achieve what are
the challenges
we say that regime of course is cleaning
up uh to the power they don't want to
give up and they are making
lives of people worse and worse every
day
they are ready to sacrifice with
well-being of bitter sense with their
lives with the faith you know to
stay in the power
so we
see a lot of attacks of propaganda on
democratic forces on people in the
country
when
any person is being detained in belarus
you feel pain even if you are abroad
because these are your people
uh they say you like active core inside
belarus
uh
so we see how uh propaganda wants to
create
this message that democratic forces are
split that we are not
like a single movement and we have to
prove uh day after day that look we are
working together
so
many challenges and for example at the
moment when
uh in this difficult situation between
russia and ukraine
um
we see how
attention to person issue
is lost somewhere and our task now is to
say look we are in the middle of this
crisis our uh
mother land is
um
given to a third party
to make this military rallies you know
to threaten uh
ukraine and it's against our national
interests but we're still there and
understand until kashank is in power uh
he will always be um threat to
regional security
and he is creating these
problems with the rhino flights with the
this hybrid attack on on europe so uh
we have to cure the core of this crisis
and it's the regime
um what is your main concern now when it
comes to the ukrainian russian conflict
that
regime is so weak
that
it would let
use
its weakness to
become a threat to our neighbors ukraine
for
we don't want to fight against our
neighbors we are in wonderful
relationship and
but regime is weak and it can be used
this weakness can be used by
other country
are you doing
active
steps concrete movements to avoid this
do you have contact to people inside of
your country what what you're doing to
stop this
of course we have communication with
people on the ground every day i'm
communicating with different groups of
people even with people from democrats
from military forces
but all those people in the regime they
are also scared and it's difficult to
ask them to be vocal in this situation
but we are building structures on the
ground we
use
like underground methods of fighting at
the moment in belarus and look there are
no relics in our country people are
scared you know kgb's raided flats all
the time
but regime behaves as if
hundreds of thousands of people in front
of their palace you know they we didn't
allow a regime to turn the page of our
history we don't give opportunity regime
to relax and say we won no you didn't
people will never accept this this
regime anymore and uh regime knows this
you represent your countries and and
talking with different leaders you had a
talk at the euro parliament
um are you satisfied with whether what
is done
and the support you're having
look i'm really grateful for
unity
of european countries of europe the usa
united kingdom and other democratic
countries
but i feel that much more
could be done in our situation
maybe faster
a lot could be done because you see the
first
important sanctions have been imposed on
the regime only in 10 months after
crackdown of
our rallies
and it's too slow
and now we see that
like democratic countries are paying
much
higher price
for
non-supporting non-timely support of
democratic movement
so they
they see the consequences of reigning
hijacking flight they have to
deal with this hybrid attack with this
migration crisis building walls uh
payment for migrants you know
but if
their decisions were faster and stronger
at the beginning uh it would be much
less
they would pay much less price
for this so now the core questions why
do you think are they not fast enough
did you talk to them you're meeting a
lot of leaders what do they tell you
what do you talk to them what did you
tell them so we say absolutely absolute
unity about the situation that uh
ukashanka uh lost his election his
illegitimate people in village don't
want him anymore but usually
authoritarian regimes have
leverages that democratic countries
don't have
they can blackmail i mean regimes can
blackmail can
you know use people's lives in their
purposes they
don't respect international laws but
democracies have to
uh
insist on diplomatic uh language
but we try to convince that
dictatorships understand only the
language of power and
economic isolation political isolation
is that what threatened the regime you
have very concrete demands
where you always ask for them you say
sanctions again against the
regime establishment of free and fair
elections in belarus how confident are
you
that
these
demands will be achieved or you will
reach what you want
consistency is what is necessary here
um
you know i'm
often here that
we need a strategic patience
but we have patience we need
strategic consistency if you say
something fulfill what you say
you say that regime breaks law that it
accumulates people
so
you know you have to
make words into actions
so sanctioned policy is the most
impactful policy towards the regime
and
i'm sure that
when we will work
together
when
sanctions will be without loopholes
so we will make uh lukashenka to
understand there is no way out of the
situation on the negotiation with people
we now act and not
because we want revenge
for this regime or whatever we want to
build new normal country where law
prevails and it can be gained only
through negotiations so our demands are
the same release all political prisoners
uh stop violence and hold new free and
fair elections this is what biller sense
demands
if we take a concrete example on the
27th of february there will be a
constitutional referendum
done by lukachenko how do you look to
this date
embers people understand and
we open eyes for all the international
society
that
this so-called referendum is
illegitimate lukash doesn't have any
right to
hold any event
and moreover
this referendum doesn't give any choice
people are made are made to choose
between lukashenko and lukashenka people
didn't ask for referendum people asking
for new elections of course we are going
to use this opportunity to
ask people uh you know to
participate in this event to
to show the attitude to the regime to so
to say once again no to lukashenka we
ask people to come to the polling
station to use this right but to
choose
all their variants uh proposed variants
to make ballot invalid
so of course we understand nobody is
going to count this ballot nobody is
going to say real numbers but it will be
opportunity for people to see each other
to understand that there are a lot of us
and
to inspire each other again
and
of course there are people who want to
buy code this referendum is their right
and of course we will use alternative
counting again to see the real picture
and we ask for international community
not to recognize this referendum
and we you know have full support from
democratic countries here um you you
also say i'm a i'm a now
i'm a politician but i'm also a mother
and you have two children how do you
explain to your children what is
happening home
it's a peter that the children of those
who had to flee the country or those who
have political prisoner in their family
had to
grow up rather fast and have to
understand
uh what is dictatorship what is cruelty
uh what is lawlessness
children very good understand that
something wrong is going in our country
and very small children explain there is
a better kashenka in our country he put
in prison my dad or mother and
people won't
get rid of him but he's so cruel you
know he's beaten people so they explain
this in their language and it's so pity
to look at that that they are
experiencing uh
this
um if you look
today in 10 years
let's imagine
where do you want your country to be
at
i know belarusians we are wonderful
nation where people are hard-working
very kind very patient and
in 10 years i'm sure with wonderful
management of new president we
will become
prosperous country where
people
get good level of lives where people
respect
the government where people
respect each other people are free to
travel and we have wonderful
relationship both with west and east and
it's possible i believe in this it's
interesting when we when you were
talking about what's happening you were
much more optimistic and smiling so to
keep optimistic and smiling when do you
think will you return back to your
country
no when you want to
make
god laugh
tell him about your plans i don't know i
really don't know
what i know is that every day i'm
working very hard to make this day
closer
because this day will be not only the
day of my returning to belarus it will
be the day of releasing thousands of
people from jails
people are suffered really enough
for their values and
you know i i really hope that it will
happen
very soon
last but not least you're you're getting
soon the carl's prize you will be
awarded with the carl's prize which is
especially for your work for freedom
democracy and to maintain human rights
what's the core message you will say
when you get this award
this award is not for me
this is the award for belarus and people
everybody in beerus
deserves
this award because everyone
wastes his time
life
you know for
the sake of our future for the sake of
our children and i'm really grateful for
those uh countries that are giving us
different prizes
they it means that
they
believe in us they understand what we
are fighting for that we share uh our
values and
it's like a step of respect for all
those who are sacrificing
with themselves
to gain
changes in belarus
thank you so much for joining us today
in our special munich security
conference youtube studio and uh enjoy
the conference thank you so much thank
you thank you
[Music]
you